[Musique]
moi je fais partie des affections
chanceux parce que et j'ai eu la
possibilité de fréquenter des
universités de cultures différentes
l'université américaine d'universités
européennes l'université moderne
africaine et surtout l'université de la
bonne manière il beaucoup d'entre vous
ne connaissent pas c'est cette
université qui m'a construit
l'université de la bonne manière
diversité de la tradition orale
l'université moderne
ma a fait de moi une tête plein une
bibliothèque m'a donné beaucoup de
connaissances et des certitudes
par exemple la science exacte
quand il ya un problème je vais chercher
l'information dans ma bibliothèque
les états unis la date anniversaire de
l'indépendance des états unis c'est
quand je vais chercher dans ma
bibliothèque les connaissances que
l'école moderne l'université moderne m'a
donné mais par contre l'université de la
tradition m'a permis de comprendre que
la vérité d'hier n'est pas toujours la
vérité d'aujourd'hui la vérité
d'aujourd'hui n'est peut-être pas
toujours la vérité de demain
mehmet de la tradition une soupe tata
cité et tous lancé cloud valley paix à
leurs âmes m'ont appris que le mot n'est
que dynamique et cette dynamique elle se
construit autour de l'arbre comme axe et
du citoyen à la périphérie entre les
deux est allé sutz êtres humains
dilara lareau n'a pas eu un pouvoir que
tous les êtres humains pour tous les
êtres vivants ont eu c'est à dire tous
les êtres vivants se déplace d'un point
a à un point b pour aller se nourrir ou
pour éviter un danger mais à l'arbre il
n'a pas voulu donner c'est à dire la
nature elle a pas donné ce pouvoir à
l'armée
mais à l'arbre elle a donné le pouvoir à
l'ab de se nourrir à partir de sa place
de se protéger contre les dangers à
partir de sa place et a donc le pouvoir
à l'arbre de nourrir tous les êtres
vivants directement ou indirectement de
guérir tous les êtres vivants
directement ou indirectement et mes
maîtres de l'université de la bonne
manière
- surtout appris que c'est le lien
l'équilibré entre l'humain et la qui
constitue véritablement le bien-être du
monde et que le citoyen ce rapport entre
l'arbre et le citoyen l' équilibre qui
doit être créé dans cette gestion c'est
ça qui constitue la base du bien-être
était ce bien être le citoyen alain la
matière première non pas dieu l'ont pas
le pétrole n'ont pas l'argent non pas la
technologie n'ont pas la science et ils
expliquent comment ils disent par deux
propos propos féminin et propose
basculant ils disent marc perez n'a nié
j'aimerais ça vaille propos masculin
mesures pérennes année propre au féminin
propos féminin s'est véritablement les
quatre fondamentaux qui font l'homme
mais qui n'est pas contrôlée par l'homme
c'est-à-dire les quatre longs mais il
peut pas contrôler sa naissance l'homme
absent parce que la fin parce qu'il a
envie de respirer parce qu'il a soit
deuxième des fondamentaux l'homme
restitue restitue parce que et à
l'émotion
l'émotion il est gay il pleure de
bonheur en pleurs le malheur il part
véritablement l'exercice physique
il sut par l'amour excusez moi il
éjacule quand il doit aller aux
toilettes
il va y faire pipi et caca ça c'est
troisième fondamentaux de propos et
enfin quatrième l'omr ces processus
tous les êtres humains le vide qu'on
soit blanc jaune et moi beau gris on est
on absorbe on restitue en main propre au
féminin propos masculin c'est ce qui est
fait de même donc on contrôle qui nous
construit chacun ils disent
l'homme est fait deux trois qui lie saba
micky liza weil 1er 2e premier décrit le
testicule cokerie c'est ça qui crée la
vie 2e 2e donnie avery a pris l'esprit
je pense donc j'existe et 3e décrit donc
il y le feu de la danse la musique ils
disent qu'à un homme chante et on danse
ce qu'il n'a pas fait
ce qui n'a pas soif il n'a pas mal au
corps il pense qu'il est bien vue c'est
toi qui lis constitue l'essence du 6
points partout sur la terre et c3 qui
lie chacun de nous doit travailler pour
véritablement atteindre ce poids qui lui
pour soi pour ses enfants
pour son entourage etc etc
est-ce qu'il ya mur manière d'expliquer
les droits humains c'est ce que
l'université de la monnaie à mabri
j'ai décidé en tant que producteurs
culturels créateur de théâtre de cinéma
d'émissions de télévision dans fait
relaxe éditorial de toutes mes créations
étaient toutes les productions qu'ils
auraient accompagné et séparera du mon
rêve c'est quoi c'est de créer une
grande industrie culturelle qui va
permettre de prendre ses valeurs les
transformer en dessin animé pour nos
enfants
les transforme en série télé pour la
société les transformer en événement
pour pouvoir permettre à ce que des
communautés véritablement s'empare de
ses valeurs et fasse que chacun d'eux
l'on accède à ces trois qu'il y ait face
de nous des citoyens dans notre famille
dans notre quartier dans notre commune
dans notre pays et dans le monde
moi je reste persuadé que si nous
travaillons ensemble accéder aux trois
qui lie tous cas dynamo madame drame et
adam keita nous allons y accéder sans
violence avec harmonie
je vais pas entrer dans le détail parce
que si j'entre dans le détail je vais
faire une thèse ici ah si c'est tout ce
que je voulais dire je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]